now back to dc lawmakers grilling big
tech ceos and
human traffickers using their platforms
and what they're
doing or not doing to stop it facebook
and google twitter execs taking tough
questions on the hill i think it's the
five
fifth time i do believe edward lawrence
from fox business has the story edward
how did this go
and would you say it was a grilling good
morning yeah it definitely was a
grilling they were a little bit caught
off guard by the anger
uh that was shown in the level of anger
from lawmakers now crossing the border
though in this
now apparently illegally starts online
in many cases some of the lawmakers are
saying that the same social media
companies
that banned former president donald
trump have become advertising conduits
offering logistical help and give
cartels access to more people
to human traffic just listen to this
exchange yesterday as
house lawmakers confronted the facebook
ceo mark zuckerberg
mr zuckerberg do you feel complicit in
any way
that your platform is assisting in this
disaster
congressman where where we have policies
and we're working to to fight this
content we have policies against scams
and
pages groups and events um like the
content that you're talking about we're
also
seeing uh the state department use our
platform to share factual information
with people
so representative buddy carter there
says that his office found facebook
pages and instagram posts
offering to take people across the u.s
border illegally for a fee
now at his news conference president
biden again seemed to give the green
light for parents to send unaccompanied
children
to the u.s border he says he's not going
to turn them away this is the kind of
information flowing from the cartels
through social media to people in south
america and the numbers reflect it last
month
171 percent more minors showed up
without parents at our southwestern
border
than in february of 2020 it's similar
increases
for all people showing up at the
southwestern border so the internet is
forever the word got out
the u.s borders open and the
administration having trouble bottling
it back
up edward lawrence watching that for us
thanks in washington